welcome to this video of playing
Yardbird and what the heck did she do
with this rating it's not the the worst
that I've seen from Emmys bouncing up
and down all the time but you also far
more often meet him with like 2/5 or
something okay let's play them Jiang
play the same Michigan getting getting a
fight right from the start okay it's
going for the d5 set up interesting yeah
I was very surprised when this was not
exactly this position but this general
set up when this was played by by
Carlton in the World Championship match
it has a longtime reputation to be as
somewhat somewhat dodgy set up and still
the now world champion played it was
successful very interesting choice okay
well of course White's general idea in
this structure is to get any form for
later attack on the on the kingside we
don't the center of course getting the
majority rolling and this is what I'm
trying to do this Bishop won't be too
looks silly but it protects the form so
that I can actually play a form soon
black can try to get the night over here
Knight a5 c4 very valid idea but black
must be am very aware that the knight on
c4 has positioned nicely but it does not
pressurized e4 anymore so on
this is in fact a very important very
important point okay if I go if for now
he might take a couple of times a play
Knight e5 using this pin
85 with the tempo so I try to increase
my control here by covering the Queen
not sure maybe this is too slow okay but
it is interesting nevertheless this
position tab
yes I thought that maybe not FIF is a
good answer to that but okay well the
Queen just goes to e6 and it's not clear
that I have gained anything from that
yeah that's really true um the question
is what about sometimes you can just
play you for anyway takes takes Knight
takes Knight f5 that is in fact
interesting and I can also go here I
wonder
I'm tough to judge and now if four was
my idea takes takes Knight takes Queen
takes the wrist night these six takes
takes Knight takes and then D 5 D 5 why
not actually 5 takes takes Queen takes
96 ok I hope I'm don't I don't overlook
something serious here
so Queen takes 96 very quickly decided
by hand it's this rookie 2 at the end or
something I don't I don't get it I mean
of course he's got a pawn for the
exchange and everything but it's still
an exchange or I don't really see the
point
there is no rookie to or anything but
that's really nothing serious I mean ok
mmm
I probably should take here yeah this is
this is a problem ok but I can no I can
now set up this pin
would be really helpful to get loops
traded here and Roxy - maybe okay Jack
got the ropes traded and now yeah my
bishop on b2 was obviously bad maybe C 1
D 2 before this kind of route I need I
will need the king okay
yeah of course I forgot about this
possibility hmm
okay I need to activate him didn't want
to to do any passive covering moves
yeah that wasn't really well played
giving up t4
yeah I just need to attack those pawn
witnesses tried to win 1 or 2 points if
he goes night to see 2 attacking my upon
I'll play a form so it's not it's not
easy for him yeah hmm time warning Jim
Bishop you want it's not a happy move
but now maybe I can just play King II -
actually no reason not to
yeah he's got this tricky nights it is
always a problem those bloody nights
check check check
so how to continue him I'm checking the
queenside pants it's got very active
pieces so it will be very difficult to
do anything here the 95 especially is
covering all the weaknesses
January nights really and 94 there's
those damn Forks really it was very
tough to lose this game very tough only
with those bloody Forks okay I can
resign that white resign nonsense really
it's just a draw of course I mean you
can can do whatever I want just not
blunder the rook yeah yeah whatever King
c2 or whatever he cannot move the pawn
simply I win one of the points and then
it's just a draw what two nights cannot
make me it's just just a simple fact
yeah of course I shouldn't should never
lose it from from here Chad I gave away
the D pawn which was really bad yeah
this wasn't great I mean white is still
better here but it's it's very tricky
obviously against the Knights this is
the kind of position that check in the
tournament game white would probably
just win but against against those
tricky pieces with no time I was really
just playing for a draw here getting
getting the the pawns off right and yeah
maybe I should have played this simply
this is the easiest job and it's an
immediate role check that's that's the
that's absolutely easiest I wonder if
this is a draw by the way if ICC
standards not quite sure actually if you
lose on time probably this is a time win
for the Knights because you can really
set up a mate yeah
yeah I think this was actually quite
quite okay here with the former this was
good and he just went into this bed
endgame for know without really being
pushed to do some check but McCain
didn't play well okay thanks for
watching